Speaker 1: On the other hand, that was a
protest. It was a logical protest because
the election was stolen. It was a
peaceful protest by my supporters,
Trump supporters. But any violence that there
was was Black Lives Matter, and it was antifa,
of course, a claim for which there is absolutely
no evidence. And despite that, it is Trump's
supporters that are being treated poorly. That's
not only an inaccurate revision of history,
it's a very dangerous one
because if it convinces many
Speaker 2: people and it's convincing
Speaker 1: quite a few, it is part of this
possible next coup attempt
Speaker 2: that we talked about
Speaker 1: on yesterday's program then. And
this is the last clip that we'll look at.
Although if this is interesting, if you can
stomach this, I encourage you to find the entire
interview. It's available online. Trump then, does
his routine of stating states in which he did very
well. He sort of stopped short of saying, I won
these states, but their states where we did well
and these are states Trump is looking at being
involved in in 2022. And so this is actually
massively consequential, and we're going to
talk about why in a moment. But first, let's
Speaker 2: look at the clip than most.
Speaker 8: But we won big numbers in Missouri,
and you didn't mention Ohio, where will also be
involved. But we have time. I mean, they won't
be there won't be primaries for quite a while
in all of those states. And we have some time
interesting things going on in this place that
I love is Pennsylvania. You have a lot of very
interesting candidates in Pennsylvania, too, so
we're going to be involved in the process. Yeah.
Speaker 7: OK. Mr. President, congratulations on
the book. Our journey together is out tomorrow.
It's available at 45 books dot com. As
always, your time is greatly appreciated
and thank you for honoring us.
Speaker 8: Well, thank you both
very much and keep up the good work. You're
doing great. Thank you. Thank you, sir.
Speaker 2: Thank you, sir.
Speaker 1: So why is this so important?
It's important because this is the clearest
Speaker 2: signal yet from Trump
Speaker 1: that he will be
involved in 2022 races, and he
Speaker 2: mentioned Missouri.
Speaker 1: He mentions Pennsylvania, and maybe
he's going to support Dr. Oz in Pennsylvania.
And he mentioned some other states. Now
this is a signal from Trump about his
intentions. The question that remains
is whether the candidates want Donald Trump
involved. But if he can raise money for them, I
imagine they are certainly going to let him do it.
And without a doubt, Trump's preference would be
be involved, endorse and campaign for
people who win and use those successes
Speaker 2: if it happens
Speaker 1: to justify running in
2024 and being the Republican nominee by saying,
Look at what I did for us in the midterms,
that's his plan is making it very clear
right now, and it very much might work